Brouhaha de conversations
...
-Ce qui nous anime,
c'est véritablement redonner
une place
aux victimes.
Le procès, c'est ce qui va rendre
aux rescapés la dignité
qu'ils ont perdue
pendant ce génocide.
Musique douce
...
-Moi, je suis toujours fébrile,
le jour J.
J'attends toujours les jurés
avec impatience.
C'est toujours la même question
qui me hante :
est-ce qu'ils vont comprendre
cette histoire ?
...
*-France Info.
*-Près de 30 ans
après la guerre civile au Rwanda
et le génocide des Tutsis,
entre 800 000
et 1 million de morts,
un ancien gendarme rwandais
est jugé
par la cour d'assises de Paris.
L'ex-militaire âgé de 66 ans
est accusé
de crimes
qu'il nie formellement.
Musique pesante
...
-Je m'appelle
Dafroza Gauthier-Mukarumongi.
Je suis née au Rwanda
il y a très longtemps déjà.
J'habite à Reims aussi
depuis une petite
quarantaine d'années.
J'ai trois enfants.
J'ai un mari,
Alain Gauthier.
Et notre histoire est directement,
malheureusement, liée au génocide.
...
-Nous, notre objectif,
c'est de poursuivre en justice
les personnes soupçonnées
d'avoir participé
au génocide perpétré
contre les Tutsis du Rwanda
et qui se trouvent
sur le territoire français.
Quand on s'est embarqués
dans ce combat pour la justice,
on ne pensait pas que ça allait
nous engager comme ça,
à ce point-là.
Depuis 94,
nous n'avons pas passé
une journée
sans parler du génocide,
sans évoquer la vie des rescapés,
la poursuite des génocidaires.
...
Les oiseaux chantent.
-Ce que nous faisons,
c'est de prendre
notre bâton de pèlerin,
d'aller au Rwanda,
d'interroger les vivants,
les survivants quand il y en a,
d'interroger les habitants
des lieux...
Si on veut
que ces génocidaires présumés
comparaissent
devant la justice,
on n'a pas d'autre choix,
en fait.
Musique pesante
...
-Biguma, c'était un adjudant-chef
à Nyanza,
dans le sud du Rwanda.
...
A Nyanza, on évoque la mort
de 90 000 personnes.
Et Biguma est mêlé
à la majorité de ces crimes.
...
Le vent souffle.
-94 a changé tout.
94, c'est l'année 0,
qui a rasé tout,
qui a rasé nos vies,
on n'est pas les seuls.
Le génocide, c'est un ouragan
qui dévaste tout,
absolument tout.
L'orage gronde.
Et il ne reste quasi rien.
...
-Le génocide remonte
très, très loin, en fait.
Des historiens veulent
nous faire croire
que le génocide
a commencé en 1994,
ils le disent quand ils témoignent
dans les procès,
mais pour nous, il remonte
beaucoup plus loin dans l'histoire.
Musique grave
-Le génocide a été le produit
d'une politique raciste
qui avait débuté au Rwanda
avec la colonisation.
...
Avant la colonisation,
il y avait des catégories sociales.
Si vous montez, vous êtes considéré
comme un Tutsi,
mais si vous êtes vraiment quelqu'un
qui reste le commun des mortels,
vous êtes considéré comme Hutu.
Tout le monde pouvait monter,
comme tout le monde
pouvait aussi descendre.
...
-On a affaire là
à un même peuple.
Les Tutsis et les Hutus partagent
les mêmes valeurs,
les mêmes croyances,
parlent la même langue.
-Quand on avait beaucoup de vaches,
on était tutsi,
quand on cultivait et qu'on avait
peu de vaches, on était hutu.
Ca n'a jamais été des races.
-Les Européens
considéraient
que dans chaque groupe de gens,
il y a ceux
qui sont supérieurs et inférieurs.
Musique sombre
-Il va toujours se trouver
des scientifiques
qui vont aller mesurer
les crânes, les nez,
les couleurs des yeux,
les cheveux, etc.
...
Ils transforment en quelque sorte
des catégories sociales
en catégories raciales.
...
Cette pensée scientifique
des Européens
va permettre de justifier
l'emprise des Tutsis,
de cette minorité, sur les Hutus.
C'est de par leur race différente
que les Tutsis ont le droit,
en quelque sorte,
de dominer la masse hutu.
-Les Batutsis,
la race dominante,
ce peuple de pasteurs s'adonne
exclusivement à l'élevage
et professe pour tout autre travail
un mépris absolu.
Les hommes se distinguent
par leur haute stature
et leur fière démarche.
Les Bahutu, qui représentent
90 % de la population,
sont des paysans bantous,
à l'âme lourde et passive,
ignorant tout souci du lendemain.
-Les Allemands,
mais surtout Les Belges,
avaient besoin d'un groupe
pour diriger le pays.
Alors, ils se sont appuyés
sur les Tutsis.
-Ils vont créer un ressentiment
de la part des Hutus
qui, jusqu'alors,
avaient un certain rôle,
et occupaient un certain nombre
de fonctions
relativement importantes.
Musique grave
...
-A partir des années 1950,
les Tutsis commencent à manifester
des velléités d'indépendance.
-Lors de la décolonisation,
il y a,
au sein de l'élite tutsi,
des idées d'indépendance,
d'indépendantisme.
Naturellement, ça fait peur
aux colonisateurs belges.
Ce qu'ils vont faire,
c'est qu'ils vont renverser
à 180 degrés leur politique,
où désormais,
les Hutus vont être favorisés.
Donc, ils vont favoriser
cette fois-ci
une prise de pouvoir,
tout simplement,
par un parti extrémiste hutu.
...
-C'est à ce moment qu'on a commencé
à considérer les Tutsis
comme des citoyens de seconde zone.
A chaque fois
qu'il y avait des problèmes,
ils étaient considérés
comme des boucs émissaires
et éliminés.
-On peut parler
à la fois de milliers de morts
et d'une émigration
extrêmement importante
d'une grande partie des Tutsis.
-On chassait les Tutsis de chez eux,
on pillait,
on brûlait...
Voilà.
Si tu pars pas,
tu es tué, tout simplement.
...
-En 1990,
les enfants expulsés,
les exilés de 1959, ont grandi
et ils ont un désir
de revenir
dans leur pays d'origine.
-Le Front patriotique rwandais
a été créé
en grande partie
par les descendants
des réfugiés de 1959
et ils ont attaqué
le pays,
à partir du 1er octobre 1990.
Musique pesante
-Il y a une sorte de panique
qui surgit
au sein des gens
qui dirigent le Rwanda, les Hutus.
Il y a à la fois la peur
du Tutsi de l'extérieur
et une grande méfiance,
une paranoïa,
en ce qui concerne
les Tutsis de l'intérieur.
Et donc, lentement mais sûrement,
on va développer
un certain nombre d'outils
pour préparer, finalement,
la population hutu à l'irréparable.
Ils chantent.
Donc, on va développer
à la fois des milices...
...
On va faire
des achats massifs d'armes
pour pouvoir
les distribuer à la population.
Et puis la fameuse création
de Radio télévision
Mille Collines,
qu'on va qualifier
de Radio machettes.
Musique pesante
*Grésillements
Propos en kinyarwanda
...
-Au début de l'année 94,
je pense que ma mère commençait
à avoir envie de nous voir,
en fait.
Bon, je vais au Rwanda.
Kigali était à feu et à sang.
Kigali,
des grenades pétaient partout.
Il y avait des assassinats ciblés
chez les Tutsis.
Donc, ma mère m'a dit :
"Faut que tu repartes.
"Faut que tu partes, parce que là,
ça va très, très mal."
J'ai écourté mon séjour.
Je suis rentrée.
Mais je savais
que j'allais pas les revoir.
Ca, c'est sûr.
C'est sûr.
D'ailleurs, tout ce que j'ai laissé,
ce jour-là...
Ca n'y est plus.
Ben moi, je...
Oui, j'ai sauvé ma peau.
Oui, puis après, le mois d'après,
c'était ce qu'on sait.
Ca se raconte pas.
Ca se vit.
-Les circonstances de la mort
des présidents rwandais et burundais
ne sont pas claires.
Hier soir,
leur avion s'est écrasé
peu avant son atterrissage
à Kigali, au Rwanda.
D'après des témoins,
l'avion a essuyé des tirs.
D'autres parlent
d'explosion avant l'atterrissage.
Musique sombre
-Le 6 avril, donc,
94, l'avion du président Habyarimana
est abattu.
Le président meurt.
Il y a une vacance de pouvoir.
Et c'est un prétexte
qui va permettre
aux Hutus extrémistes
de prendre le pouvoir
et de gérer
la mise en oeuvre du génocide.
...
Brouhaha
Ah, il y a un match !
...
Raphaël, c'était un cousin
qui habitait ici, à Nyanza.
Il était enseignant.
Il a été joueur de foot,
ici,
et il avait cinq enfants.
Coup de sifflet
Applaudissements
...
Et il a été ramené avec sa famille,
et lui, l'histoire dit
qu'on lui aurait coupé la tête
et on aurait joué au foot
avec sa tête, ici,
à l'intérieur même de ce stade.
Voilà.
Musique pesante
...
Ca demande déjà beaucoup d'énergie
pour poursuivre
cette quête de justice.
...
Alors, évidemment,
quand les histoires familiales
s'en mêlent...
Tomber sur sa famille,
sur ses cousins, ses amis,
ça fait perdre pied.
Musique dramatique
...
Raphaël était grand et beau.
J'ai quelques photos, mais...
...
*La radio grésille.
-Ils sont bien gardés, hein ?
-Ben, oui, voilà les cercueils.
Ah, oui. Oui, oui, oui...
Oh là là...
-Ici, on peut trouver
38 000 Tutsis.
50 % qui sont morts
tués par Biguma et ses alliés.
Oui...
Ici.
-Ouais, toute la famille, hein.
Dans ce cercueil.
Voilà.
-Une pensée pour eux.
Vous n'aviez pas de photos ?
-Non, on a tout brûlé.
-Disparues aussi.
C'est ça aussi, le drame,
le drame de....
On nous a volé nos photos aussi.
-On nous a volé nos souvenir.
En brûlant les maisons,
en les pillant,
on nous a tout pris nous aussi.
-Lorsque j'étais enfant...
-Nous, c'est pareil.
-Ma mère,
elle avait sa petite caisse en bois
et avec toutes les photos
que mon frère envoyait d'Europe
avec des enfants,
des photos quand on était petites.
J'ai pas de photo
quand je suis petite,
tout est parti
avec la petite caisse.
-Toutes les photos...
C'est ce qui a permis d'identifier
certaines victimes.
On a retrouvé la carte d'identité
dans les poches, les carnets...
-Des béquilles.
-Des handicapés.
Y a même...
-Les bigoudis.
-Même les bigoudis.
C'est la carte d'identité.
Là, ici, je pense que c'est marqué
"Hutu" et c'est barré.
Et "Tutsi" à côté.
-Ca, c'est la signature
de ta condamnation à mort.
C'est pour ça qu'on peut pas laisser
quand même des gens qui ont fait ça,
les laisser vivre
non plus tranquilles.
-Cette période de 3 mois
du génocide, on va vivre
comme des fantômes.
Nous passons nos nuits au téléphone,
on envoie des fax,
on envoie des appels au secours.
-Y a pas beaucoup de mots
pour raconter
ce qu'on pouvait ressentir,
cette culpabilité qui vous rongeait,
qui me rongeait,
je venais de les laisser.
Je les vois encore.
Cette image
où tout le monde me fait...
-Le 8 avril,
je suis dans mon bureau
au collège Jeanne-d'Arc à Reims.
Je téléphone à la paroisse
où je sais que la maman de Dafroza
s'est réfugiée.
Et le père Blanchard m'annonce
que la maman de Dafroza
a été tuée le matin.
Des militaires
sont venus chasser
tous les réfugiés de l'église.
Ils ont tiré dans le tas.
La maman de Dafroza
fait partie des victimes.
J'ai la lourde charge,
en rentrant le soir à la maison,
d'annoncer la mort de la maman
et de la grand-mère
des enfants.
-Ma mère s'appelait
Suzanne Mukamusoni.
Musique pesante
...
Les oiseaux crient.
Alain adore les oiseaux.
Moi tu vois,
depuis 94,
j'ai une phobie, presque.
En 94, les rapaces
s'en sont donné à coeur joie.
Ils n'arrêtaient pas
de manger les corps des nôtres.
...
Dans notre trauma, sûrement,
tu penses tout de suite à ça.
...
Tu ne penses pas à la beauté
de l'oiseau.
Je ne vois pas un rapace
en termes de poésie.
C'est malheureux, hein ?
-Un génocide ne réussit
jamais complètement
puisqu'il y a toujours des rescapés,
et ces rescapés sont là
pour pouvoir témoigner
de ce qui s'est passé.
Tout repose sur des témoignages,
dans le cadre du génocide
des Tutsis.
Beaucoup de documents écrits
ont été détruits.
Depuis 30 ans,
beaucoup de témoins ne sont plus.
Et si on ne récolte pas
ces témoignages,
on ne pourra plus organiser
des procès en France,
donc il y a urgence.
Musique pesante
...
C'était une région habitée
par beaucoup de Tutsis.
Y a des collines ou il n'y avait
que des Tutsis, d'ailleurs,
et où aujourd'hui, malheureusement,
il ne reste personne.
...
-Qu'est-ce que c'est beau !
-Merci.
Propos en kinyarwanda
...
-C'est très fort.
-Et tous les gens écoutent.
-Tout le monde écoute, mais bon,
c'est leur histoire, aussi, hein.
C'est terrible.
Comment veux-tu
qu'on prenne pas toutes ces ondes ?
-Ah oui, bonjour.
-C'est le plus important.
-A la fin du génocide,
Biguma s'est réfugié au Congo.
Il a dû y avoir des magouilles
mais en tout cas, il s'est retrouvé
en France.
-En fin de juin 1994,
La France
a mis en place ce qu'on a appelé
l'opération Turquoise,
pour créer des zones de sécurité.
-La France
a décidé de lancer
une opération humanitaire au Rwanda.
Je crois
que le premier objectif est atteint
avec encore une fois
tous ces sourires
sur vos visages.
-Mais la zone Turquoise
n'a été qu'une sorte de couloir
pour faire fuir
une grande partie de la population
et exfiltrer les autorités
qui venaient de commettre
le génocide.
Musique pesante
...
-Et donc, l'opération Turquoise
va permettre à des centaines
de génocidaires Hutus,
des responsables des génocidaires,
de quitter le territoire rwandais
et qui par la suite iront
pour certains en France,
pour d'autres en Belgique
ou au Canada.
-Ici en France,
ils se sont refait
une virginité.
Ce sont de bons parents.
Ce sont de bons voisins.
Ce sont de bons citoyens
qui s'impliquent
dans des associations humanitaires,
voire des bons chrétiens.
-Vous imaginez,
nous avons nos familles décimées.
Et vous voyez déferler
dans nos pays, ici,
les assassins de nos familles.
Mais c'est un scandale !
C'est pas possible.
N'importe qui
s'indignerait, je pense.
...
-Depuis plus de 20 ans,
nous avons déposé
plus d'une trentaine de plaintes.
Et jusqu'à maintenant,
malheureusement,
seules cinq personnes ont été jugées
et condamnées.
...
La France, c'est pratiquement
le seul pays aujourd'hui
qui refuse toujours
d'extrader ces personnes
vers le Rwanda,
où ils auraient déjà été jugés,
d'où ce grand nombre de dossiers
qui s'amoncellent
sur le bureau des juges,
qui ne sont pas assez nombreux.
Nous ne cessons depuis 25 ans
de dénoncer une lenteur
insupportable pour les victimes.
En 2015, nous avons reçu
une lettre anonyme dénonçant Biguma.
Il travaillait
à l'université de Rennes
comme responsable
de la sécurité.
Donc immédiatement,
nous nous sommes emparés
de ce dossier.
-Les rescapés,
c'est pas eux qui ont le plus vu.
C'est-à-dire qu'un rescapé,
soit il se cachait
dans un trou de souris,
soit il était caché
dans un plafond d'un bienfaiteur.
Mais par contre, les tueurs,
on a besoin de leur parole,
de leurs témoignages,
parce que c'est eux qui savent.
-Vous savez, entrer dans une prison,
c'est pas si facile que ça
quand on sait qui c'est
qui l'habite.
Propos en kinyarwanda
...
-Il accepte de parler ?
De parler du génocide ici à Nyanza ?
...
-Qu'ils vous mentent
ou qu'ils vous mentent pas,
il faut les interroger.
Au détour d'une phrase,
vous allez comprendre des choses.
Gros menteur professionnel.
Il a eu la perpète,
mais en fait,
la seule chose qu'il sait,
c'est que Biguma a tiré...
-Il a tué un boeuf !
-Il a tué
le taureau des vaches...
Non, j'avais pas envie de traduire,
parce que j'en peux plus.
-Non, mais j'étais dans un état...
-Il faut dire qu'il n'a dégagé
que des ondes négatives.
Tu ne pouvais pas être bien.
-Si c'est ça...
-J'avais envie de lui dire
"tais-toi", mais il continuait.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
Musique douce
A chaque fois,
c'est de très jolis endroits.
C'est incroyable, hein.
Ouais.
C'est le décalage
entre le macabre
et la beauté.
Il est toujours saisissant.
Ouais. Quel que soit l'endroit,
même nous, on s'habitue pas.
On croit qu'on pourrait,
mais on s'habitue pas,
malheureusement.
Je sais pas
s'il faut s'habituer, d'ailleurs.
Allez !
Brouhaha de conversations
...
-Nyanza, ça a été aussi
un grand lieu
de résistance
de la part des Tutsis.
Quand les Tutsis se réfugiaient
en haut des collines,
ils se défendaient
à coups de pierres,
si bien qu'il a fallu parfois
plusieurs attaques,
soit des miliciens,
soit des gendarmes,
pour venir à bout
de leur résistance.
Des oiseaux chantent.
...
Musique pesante
-Ichi.
Ni.
San.
Shi.
Go.
Roku.
Shichiou.
-Je m'appelle Sinzi Tharcisse.
Je suis maître en karaté.
J'ai commencé le karaté en 78,
et maintenant,
je suis ceinture noire, 7e dan.
Comme la majorité me connaissait
comme un karatéka,
quand je donnais les ordres,
ils acceptaient.
J'ai expliqué aux gens
que "ceux qui viennent vous tirer,
"ils ont deux bras, deux jambes,
deux yeux,
"du sang rouge comme nous."
Il faut pas qu'ils aient peur.
Il faut qu'ils engagent le combat.
En utilisant les pierres,
on peut les lancer
à quelqu'un qui a un fusil.
Si nous lançons ensemble
les pierres contre lui,
tu parviens à lutter.
On a résisté contre eux
pendant au moins deux semaines.
Et après,
il y avait une petite route,
qu'on a suivie vers le Burundi.
Il y avait beaucoup de barrières
qu'il fallait franchir.
Le vent souffle.
...
C'était pas facile,
parce que chaque barrière,
on faisait un combat.
Musique grave
...
Nous avons perdu beaucoup de gens.
Avant, on avait fait
un petit recensement.
On était 3480.
Ceux qui ont pu franchir
la rivière vers le Burundi
étaient juste...
118.
...
J'avais une grande famille.
Y compris ma femme et mon enfant,
tout a été perdu.
...
-Biguma, il va être
face à la justice,
il va être
face aux parties civiles,
que nous sommes,
et surtout, il va être
face aux victimes.
C'est important pour le Rwanda,
pour l'écriture de cette histoire,
des lieux
et l'histoire du génocide,
et en cela,
on peut se dire :
"Voilà à quoi ça sert aussi,
notre travail."
Salut !
Salut, cocotte !
*-Ca va ?
-On est comme vous.
-Comme vous.
On attend.
*-Vous voyez, quoi.
On croise les doigts !
-Oui, oui.
-Ouais.
Quand même, on commence
à avoir un noeud dans le ventre.
Moi, ça commence tout doucement
à s'installer.
Le stress.
Le stress du verdict.
Ouais.
Je m'habitue toujours pas, hein.
*-Non, mais aie confiance.
-Oui, oui, oui.
*-Aie confiance.
-Oui, oui, on a confiance.
*-Bisous.
Musique pesante
...
Conversations indistinctes
-Moi, j'étais dans un stress,
t'as jamais vu ça.
...
Elles chantent.
-Je pense, à cet instant même,
à toutes les victimes
à qui Biguma
et ses pairs ont infligé
la perpétuité.
En fait, les rescapés vivent,
ont été condamnés à perpétuité
depuis presque 30 ans.
Il faut le comprendre.
Je vais pouvoir leur dire
qu'ils ne sont pas venus
dire des choses pour rien.
Ils sont venus le dire ici,
à Paris,
dans cette cour d'assises,
et leur souffrance a été entendue.
Et merci.
-MERCI ! MERCI ! MERCI !
-C'est la justice
qu'il faut remercier.
Musique douce
...
-Le génocide,
ça aurait pu être un événement
qui aurait pu
faire exploser notre couple.
Mais... Je crois que c'est un peu
ce qui nous a soudés
encore davantage.
On avait ce combat à mener
et, je pense, ce combat
qu'on ne peut plus abandonner,
qu'on mènera
jusqu'à la fin de nos jours.
...
On aura au moins la satisfaction
d'avoir fait peut-être
quelque chose de...
D'important dans notre existence.
Dafroza dit souvent, effectivement :
"On est des gens peu importants,
"mais qui avons été entraînés
"dans des événements
excessivement importants."
Bon, voilà.
C'est notre histoire.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA